let's talk about some amazing benefits of
simply taking a hot bath and i'm talking about
temperature 40 degrees celsius or a 104 degree
fahrenheit for 30 minutes the biggest benefit
is anxiety and depression there's several studies
that i'm going to put down below that back this up
but if you have anxiety or depression this simple
thing can greatly help you and that is because
number one it's going to lower cortisol cortisol
is a stress hormone less stress less anxiety
number two higher levels of serotonin serotonin
is the happy hormone it's a hormone that helps you
feel calm it gives you a sense of well-being and
if you have that you're gonna have less anxiety
and definitely less depression number three it's
gonna improve your sleep you're gonna get a much
deeper sleep so what happens is this heat actually
relaxes you so when you sleep your melatonin
actually causes your body to get a little cooler
and so by raising the heat before you go to bed
you get a rebound effect or a resetting effect
and you actually become a little colder and your
body will get a much better sleep when it's on the
colder side try to sleep when you have a hot flash
it doesn't work right all right number four
your muscles are going to feel very relaxed
one thing that i recommend is taking epsom
salts magnesium to your bath and lemon balm oil
which is very very relaxing and calming people
take this as a t or a supplement it will help
you decrease chronic pain and stiffness now one
contraindication would be if you have acute pain
let's say you're in a recent injury and you
have swelling taking a hot bath might not be
the best thing to do you want to put cold on
that injury like a cold pack ice would be best
but for chronic pain stiffness great you're gonna
have more flexibility number six it can help you
lower your blood pressure because it increases
nitric oxide which actually is a vasodilator
now on the flip side if you have heart
pain like angina pain or chest pain
not a good idea to take a hot bath and one more
contraindication if you if you get lightheaded
easily and you take this hot bath right and
let's say for example the heat increases all
the circulation you have blood in the muscles and
then you stand up and you get really dizzy because
you don't your body isn't adapting to that that
well so you don't want to be fainting and then
injure yourself number seven it has the
ability to potentially help stabilize your
insulin levels i found some interesting research
on that i put a link down below and number eight
it can enhance your immunity because you're
in inducing a fever if you have an infection
a viral infection or even a bacterial infection
and you keep your body really really warm to the
point where you're sweating or you take a hot
bath you're going to help kill off pathogens
so inducing a fever is a very good thing and
then you climb in bed and you wear a lot of
clothes and you just sweat all right there
you have it the eight benefits of a hot bath
a decrease in anxiety and depression being number
one hey before you go real quick i have a course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course i want you to take it and
here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today